MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 108 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Mark Mandel, and I'm here
with my colleague, Melanie
Warrick.
How are you doing
today, Melanie?
MELANIE WARRICK:
Happy new year, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: It's the
beginning of the year,
trying to get back into
the groove of things.
MELANIE WARRICK: Trying to.
Did you have a good holiday?
MARK MANDEL: I did.
How was yours?
MELANIE WARRICK: It was good.
It was good.
It was low-key, which is nice.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
So this week, we've got
some friends of yours.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah,
they're my friends.
We hang out all the time.
MARK MANDEL: That's
what I figured.
MELANIE WARRICK:
At the pool, yeah.
So yes, this week, we're
going to be talking to Malika
Cantor and Peter Norvig.
And they're going to tell us all
about Launchpad Studio, which
is basically a program that
supports startups-- especially
machine learning startups.
Before we get into
the interview,
we're going to, of
course, start off
with the cool things of
the week and at the end
with the question of the week.
And our question of the week
is going to be about how--
if you're a startup, how would
you get credits to work on GCP?
Before we get into the cool
thing of the week, what
we do want to do is briefly
mention about vulnerabilities
that have come out last week
around our modern computers,
and specifically
these vulnerabilities
are related to
modern processors.
And they impact things like
your personal computer,
your mobile devices,
and the cloud.
Now, there is a lot
of content out there.
There's many different links,
and we'll definitely provide
some of these on our website.
And we have some
great information
that our security group
has done on this on a blog
that we will provide
around GCP and how they're
working to support that.
But the main thing
to understand is
that Meltdown and Spectre
are two vulnerabilities
that you want to be aware of.
You want to make sure you're
updating your operating system.
You want to make sure
that you are updating
all the things whenever
you have the opportunity
to on your phones, on your
laptops, on whatever cloud
services you're working with.
And Mark-- I think you wanted to
touch on this briefly as well?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
We're going to link
to all the blog posts.
We are not security experts.
I think Melanie knows way
more about this than I do.
She can talk about it for ages.
But most importantly, definitely
upgrade all the things.
One of the things that I'm just
going to literally read off
here for Google Cloud, right?
So if you're running Compute
Engine and Kubernetes Engine,
Dataflow, Dataproc--
there are some extra customer
actions that are needed.
Again, links are
in the show notes,
but definitely go through those.
Make sure you get
those implemented
as soon as you possibly can.
MELANIE WARRICK: All right.
So check out the
links, make sure you're
up to speed on
that, and let's talk
about cool things of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, absolutely.
So every time we seem
to come on the podcast,
we talk about GPUs
getting cheaper.
So why don't we talk about
GPUs getting cheaper?
So we're introducing preemtible
GPUs, which is kind of neat.
So if you ever used
preemtible GCE instances--
so instances that may
die in about 24 hours,
but you get a very large
deduction in price when you use
them--
you're now able to use GPU
instances on those, now in beta
and available for GPUs
on preemtible instances.
We'll have a link
in the show notes
as well to the blog post, which
links to the documentation
and how you can do them.
But basically, if you want to do
batch type processing for GPUs,
and you want it to be a
lot cheaper to do it--
especially if you're using
preemtible instances already--
this is a really
nice thing for you.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
Cheaper is always better.
All right.
And the other cool
thing of the week
is that we have a
couple of awesome lists
that we wanted to
share with everybody.
We've got some links we'll put
into the website as always.
But specifically, if you've
played around with GitHub,
you've seen the awesome
list of awesomeness.
There are some awesome
lists for TensorFlow.
There are awesome
lists for Kubernetes.
There's awesome lists for GCP--
Google Cloud Platform-- itself.
And the awesome lists are
really using contributors
contributing what they think
are some really great training
resources as well as real world
application samples, libraries,
analytics.
They put out there
what they think
are good tools and resources to
have access to and consolidate
that down into a list.
And I think, Mark, you said
you found in here something
that you guys had built?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I didn't realize it.
I was just looking at this now.
There was a GRPC sample
that myself, Sandeep Dinesh,
and a couple of other
developer advocates
also did some work on
where we took the old game
Simon with the
multi-colors and made
it playable over the internet
using GRPC and Kubernetes.
And that's on the list,
which I feel a little proud.
It's quite nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: You should.
You should feel very
good about yourself.
MARK MANDEL: That's really good.
Cool.
And finally is a
really nice cool thing
of the week that is coming
from the community, which
is really cool.
I'm going to butcher your
name, I'm really sorry.
I'm going to go with
Will Fuks, maybe?
A data scientist at
Dafiti Group wrote
a Medium post called "How We
Implemented a Fully Serverless
Recommender System Using GCP."
This is a really cool
article, and they
used App Engine, BigQuery,
Google Cloud Storage, Dataproc,
Datastore, Dataflow to build
a recommendation engine,
but they also talk through the
recommendation algorithm, which
I love is called DIMSUM--
I don't know why, but
that's fantastic-- basically
to build a collaborative
filtering recommendation
engine.
It's a really good read.
You should totally check it out.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
All right, well,
now that we know
what our cool things
of the week are,
we're going to go ahead and
jump into the main content.
So we are excited that we have
with us Malika Cantor, who
is the global lead
of Launchpad Studio,
and Peter Norvig, who is the
research director of machine
learning at Google.
So before we get started and to
talking about Launchpad Studio,
we want to talk a little
bit about your backgrounds.
So please introduce
yourself a little more.
MALIKA CANTOR: Yeah.
So my name is Malika Cantor.
As you mentioned, I'm the
global lead at Launchpad Studio.
Launchpad sits under
developer relations at Google.
We are basically the
accelerator engine of Google,
so we run different
accelerator initiatives
focused on supporting
various startup
ecosystems across the world.
And Studio is focused on
supporting specifically applied
AI and machine learning
companies globally.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thanks.
And Peter, we don't
really know who you are,
so do you mind telling us
a little about yourself?
PETER NORVIG: Hi.
I'm Peter.
Norvig I'm a director of
research here at Google.
I've been at Google since 2001.
Company was a little
bit smaller then.
And I've been
focusing on machine
learning for a long time,
working on various tools
and applications.
And about a year ago, I started
getting involved with Launchpad
to help others learn
how to use those tools.
MELANIE WARRICK: And you did
write the canonical book on AI
that most people tend to look
back to with Stuart Russell.
PETER NORVIG: That's right.
So I'm in the dot
com domain now,
but I've had all
the top levels--
as in dot edu, and was
professor for a while,
I was in dot gov in
computer science at NASA--
and along the way,
wrote a textbook
and got involved in
writing about the project.
MELANIE WARRICK: Got a little
bit of background there.
I know, Malika, we were talking
about it too-- that you've
had some great experiences
around the VC space,
especially in China, and
we want to get into that
a little further later.
But first, let's talk a little
bit about Launchpad Studio.
So you're explaining
an overview of it,
but what led to this project?
What inspired you guys
to get going with it?
MALIKA CANTOR: Sure.
So as you mentioned, I was
working in venture capital,
investing in applied
AI, machine learning,
and robotics companies
for a little while.
And one of the things I realized
was that a lot of the startups
didn't really have
the tools that they
needed to be successful.
And so one of my thoughts
was, well, where can
I go, and what can I do to
actually make a difference?
And this was about
six months ago.
I started, like Peter, getting
involved with the Launchpad
team and saw a great opportunity
to build a program that
would actually allow us to
gather more insights on what
startups working on
applied machine learning
in different industries
actually needed,
and for us to then
go back to Google
and other potential
large tech companies
and inform them on what were
the tools that these startups
needed to actually
implement things at scale
and grow and be successful?
So that was sort of why I
got involved very early on.
We started talking with Peter
about his interest in, again,
gathering these insights--
almost like
developing a lab where
we were working with
great companies,
trying different
things with them,
bringing them amazing
mentors, and then
figuring out if there
were any sort of learnings
across these different companies
and industries that would then
indicate that there was
an opportunity to build
a tool on the Google side.
And so this could be an API.
This could be a
new type of service
that would then have impacts
across the startup ecosystem
and everywhere in the world
and across industries.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
the program itself--
it's a six month incubator
program to bring in startups,
is that right?
MALIKA CANTOR: Effectively, yes.
So it's a six month program.
So once we decided
that we basically
wanted to develop all
of these insights,
we started thinking sort
of from first principles
how it would make
sense to set it up.
And we decided together to
focus on one specific industry
vertical at a time to
allow us to really go
deep and understand
what was going on there
and gather really
solid insights.
So right now, we're
focused on the applications
of AI, machine learning,
and health care and biotech.
So we basically
onboard companies
on a rolling basis that are
focused on this vertical.
We already have four
companies that we've
been working with for
a couple of months
and checking in with them
every couple of weeks.
They come in and work
with us every few months,
and we'll be onboarding
new companies actually
just in two weeks.
We have a big Next Event.
And so they come in,
they meet with a lot
of different product
teams at Google,
but also mentors outside.
And then in this
whole process, we're
basically gathering information
about some of their challenges.
So for instance, I've
been using TensorFlow,
but I just can't figure
out how to scale up
this part of my infrastructure.
Or I have this data set, but
especially in the health care
space, the disease I'm
looking at only allows
for me to have quite
a limited data set.
How can I amplify and augment
that data set to actually use
some of the models that are best
used in the machine learning
space?
A lot of these
types of questions
we're already starting
to see, and I'd
love to talk more about some
of the other overarching
challenges that we're
already starting to identify.
MARK MANDEL: So you're
actually talking about that.
In the beginning, you said
there are these tools that
are missing as though
it was the tools that
are missing for those
sort of problems
that people are trying to solve.
Is that kind of the gist?
MALIKA CANTOR: Yeah, and I might
also let Peter jump in here.
I think all of this is
very much a hypothesis.
We sort of came at this-- and
maybe a good analogy is we
were thinking, all right,
lean startup methodologies.
We've been accustomed
to hearing this term,
and we are thinking about
it with machine learning.
And this is something I started
seeing already in my VC days--
is does it really work?
Can you fail fast?
Can you pivot as
a company that's
leveraging machine learning?
And our general sort
of understanding
was, well, no actually.
We don't really think
that it's possible,
and it's because the
tools are lacking.
There are some tools--
like TensorFlow is an
incredible tool, GCP--
we have a lot of
other ones out there,
and other people are
building great tools too.
But it's still extremely
difficult as a company
leveraging these
new technologies
to do what we think startups
should be able to do.
And so through Studio, our hope
is to really try to understand
what are the limitations of
the tools that are already
on the market-- which are
quite limited, to be honest--
and then inform what are tools
that we should be building
to hopefully make it easier and
easier for startups to pivot
and to fail fast in the
machine learning space.
PETER NORVIG: So I think it's
a combination of the tools
and the best practices and
the knowledge and experience.
So I came to this.
I had been working
internally with teams,
where a large
percentage of the team
have PhDs in machine
learning, right?
And so they had some
background in intuition
about what to build, but
it was still really hard.
And now we want to say,
well, not everybody
has that luxury of
being able to have
a bunch of experts in machine
learning on your team.
Maybe you're in your domain--
whether it's health care,
energy, or transportation,
or whatever your
company is doing--
and you mostly have
experts in that.
And they don't have the
background that we had access
to, but you have an idea
that you have some data,
you want to do something
useful with that data,
and you want to
produce a product.
How can we do that?
And some of it is having the
right tool, but some of it
is just knowing what
the whole process is
of how you go about
starting from the raw data,
or even how do you go
about collecting data
if you don't have any yet and
building the whole pipeline
and evolving that
and keeping going?
And we just don't have
experience with that.
We've done a lot of
one by ones, but if you
look at the history of
software engineering,
we've been figuring out how to
build software for 50 years.
We've only been
trying to figure out
how to build machine
learning systems
for a small number of years.
So understanding how all that
works is the key challenge now.
MELANIE WARRICK: And you've
had the resources, finally,
to be able to experiment
with building up this machine
learning.
But barriers, I know,
are definitely people.
PETER NORVIG: Yeah,
so you see there
has been this big explosion
in the last couple of years,
and I think that's a couple
of things coming together.
A lot of it, as you say, has
to do with the resources--
that now more and
more data is online
as the internet is
everywhere, and data is
being captured in digital form.
So that's available.
Far greater computing power--
that wasn't available in the
past to be able to do things
that you couldn't try before.
And just I think one
success builds on another--
that if somebody proves
they can do something,
then somebody else says,
well, that worked for them.
I think I can do it now, too.
MELANIE WARRICK: Out
of the four companies
that you're working
with currently,
what are some of the
tools that they are using
and then also some of the
tooling that you both think
could definitely--
I mean, we're talking on it--
but anything specific that's
standing out that you
think could be useful?
MALIKA CANTOR: Yeah.
So in the companies
right now-- again,
we're in the early
days of the program.
A lot of it is mentorship--
giving insights in terms of
how they could be leveraging,
for instance, GCP
better, some of the APIs
that we've already
built. They're
working with teams like the
Cloud Machine Learning Engine
team, the Cloud AI
team, but then also
the Android Things
team, which is
trying to sort of push a lot of
learning onto the device now.
We're basically working with a
lot of different product teams
that are coming in
and mentoring startups
on what are some of the
services that we have already
that some of these companies
could be leveraging as part
of their stack so that they
don't build that themselves,
because there's no point there.
What's interesting to the
software engineering point
that Peter was talking
about is a lot of the issues
that we're seeing startups
are having is actually
around architecture.
With software
development, you're
thinking about building
an end product.
But with machine
learning, you're
thinking about how to build
a scalable data pipeline
and how to retrain a model.
And the end product is
almost like a byproduct.
It's not necessarily what
you're moving towards.
And so we're starting
to try to figure out
are there things that
we could be building?
And we definitely are on
the way to this already
with initiatives
like AutoML in terms
of automating certain parts
of this process of building
your software engineering
and development to help
these startups do this
more quickly and better--
the concept of potentially
automating DevOps also.
I think there's a lot
of opportunities here.
But I think that that
is one thing that we've
seen that's been really
interesting aside
from other problems like I
mentioned around data, UI/UX.
To Peter's point,
there aren't tools
for understanding how
regulation is going
to affect your product,
and so there it
becomes more about
best practices
and sharing best
practices across
these different companies that
are working in one industry.
Our hope is maybe that we
can even build a curriculum
to try to help inform--
OK, well, be aware
of regulation.
Be aware of how to
go about building,
how to do software
development, how
to think about
your data pipeline,
how to think about UI and UX.
And so, again, to
Peter's point, it
goes beyond just
the idea of tools.
It's more about sort of
sharing best practices
and learning from one another.
MARK MANDEL: So that actually
sounds really interesting.
I'm quite curious.
When you're talking,
Peter, about the scarcity
of resources in terms of
people with the knowledge,
are you finding that one
of the big challenges
is that people who may come in
without that machine learning
or AI knowledge have
a more, I'm going
to say quote unquote,
"traditional" software
development background, so
the pipeline and the way
that they build things for
machine learning and AIs is--
I don't know how different--
but different enough
that it's causing a disconnect
or that's a big hurdle?
Are you finding
that a challenge?
PETER NORVIG: Yeah,
I think that's right.
So one of it is really
changing the mindset for what
you're trying to do, right?
In traditional
software engineering,
you're kind of thinking like
a mathematician or a logician.
And you say, well,
in the end point,
I could sort of prove
my program correct.
And in reality, you only
do that in the classroom.
You don't do it for
any realistic program,
but you're sort of
aiming in that direction.
I mean, we have tools
like test frameworks,
where you're making
assertions, and the assertions
are of the form the result of
this should be equal to that,
or this should be true.
So it's very
binary, true/false--
either you got it or you don't.
But with machine learning,
it's not like that.
It's not mathematical.
It's more like empirical
or scientific endeavor,
so it's like doing
biology, where
you do an experiment
on the world,
you observe the results
of the experiment.
It's not that it's
true or false,
it's just most of the time
it's going to be this,
and some of the time it's
going to be something else.
And so making that
change from thinking
from a logic true
false to a kind
of probabilistic messy world--
that's hard for a lot
of people, to give up
on what they thought
was a solid bedrock
and now embrace
this uncertainty.
MARK MANDEL: Kind of the
what do you mean this is only
going to happen sometimes?
PETER NORVIG: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: So one of
the things I wanted to know
is what do you think is making--
or what kind of companies do
you accept into the program?
What makes them successful
in this type of program?
MALIKA CANTOR: Yes, so
our selection criteria
is quite simple.
So first, it's, are you
applying machine learning or AI
to the industry that
we've said we're
focused on at the present time?
Which is health care
and biotech right now,
and we're going to be
announcing other industry
tracks in the course of 2018.
The next one is are
you trying to solve
a specific challenge
related to machine learning
in the next six months?
And the reason why that is
part of our selection criteria
is we don't want to
basically take startups
in the wrong direction.
There are companies
that are going
to be implementing AI machine
learning at some point,
there are some companies
that never will.
And we just want to make sure
that the companies that we do
work with-- because we put a
tremendous amount of resources
and time on our end,
but we also expect a lot
from the companies in terms
of being there in the program,
implementing a lot of the
feedback that we give them.
We want it to be core
to what their roadmap is
in the next six months.
One thing that I should
clarify is our main engagement
mechanism with the startups.
So we don't actually
invest in the companies.
It's a slightly untraditional
accelerator program
in that we actually
get them to draw up
a project proposal of what
they want to accomplish
with Google in the
space of six months,
and we select them based
on their project proposal.
So they actually have to give
us metrics, deliverables,
goals for what they
want to achieve,
and then we give them a lot
of feedback in the selection
process.
And then based on that
project, we actually
admit them into the program.
MELANIE WARRICK:
What kind of metrics?
MALIKA CANTOR: It
really would depend.
So if you're a computer
vision company looking
at cell dynamics,
and your project
is focused on improving
precision accuracy of detection
of a certain kind of disease
looking at those cells,
then it would be improving
your precision accuracy
from 83% to 96%.
And that would be that
metric that we're basically
working on together.
But if it's a company working
in the natural language space,
then it might be
slightly different.
It might be more about how many
errors can we detect in speech?
So it really depends from
one company to another.
But yeah, that's, I'd say, is
the main selection criteria
for sure.
For us, it's less about
selling Google products.
We don't really have a very
clear sort of direct gaining
back to Google, but Peter
and I definitely-- when we're
looking at these
companies-- are thinking
about what can we learn.
And sometimes it's
even more just
from a personal intellectual
perspective of, wow,
this company is doing
something that we never
thought would be possible,
and we think there's something
really interesting
to learn here.
But definitely we're,
as I mentioned earlier,
trying to figure out what
Google could be doing
and building to make this
whole ecosystem successful.
So the more a company gives
us insights into that,
the better it's going
to be, because we're
trying to do things
at scale here
beyond just making these four
companies and other companies
in the program successful too.
MARK MANDEL: So I'm
actually curious
almost at a higher level too.
You obviously have
verticalized in the ML space,
but now I'm also curious.
Why specifically focusing on ML?
The startup space is huge.
We do a lot of stuff
across Google Cloud.
Why the emphasis
specifically on ML?
MALIKA CANTOR: Yeah.
And I'll definitely let
Peter jump in here too.
From a Launchpad
perspective, there's
actually another
phenomenal program
that's being run out of
Launchpad called Launchpad
Accelerator that's been
running for a few years now,
been extremely successful.
And what they focus on is
supporting growth stage
startups in emerging markets.
And the whole vision
of Launchpad--
so we're affiliated
with Ecosystem--
which our whole vision and
mission is to support startup
ecosystems everywhere
in the world--
is to identify startup
ecosystems that we think
are particularly
under-supported.
And so with Accelerator,
it was thinking
about next billion users.
What could we be doing
with startups globally
that would actually give
us insights and really make
an impact?
And then with Studio, again,
the thought process was similar.
We have this, as
Peter was saying,
this revolution going on-- this
boom of more and more startups
that are starting to for better
or for worse use AI machine
learning in certain cases
not in a very real way.
But we identified a need and
also an opportunity for Google
to really make a
difference here--
to, as Peter said, use some of
our expertise of building some
of these products
internally and actually see
if we can teach anything
and learn anything
from these companies that
are going really deep looking
at specific use cases and
trying to scale and productize
some of the these things
we've been working on
for a few years.
PETER NORVIG: Yeah.
I think at Google,
we have the luxury
of in some ways being able
to see into the future.
We're at such a scale that we
run into some of the problems
and opportunities
before other people who
are at a smaller scale.
So we've been doing
this for a while,
and we've seen
these opportunities.
And now we see a
way to share that
to help other companies overcome
what we've done in the past
that they're just
starting to face now.
MELANIE WARRICK: You were
saying before that there's
mentorship that's provided.
It's a six month program.
Is it similar to some of the
other incubators out there,
or is it different?
Is there certain things that
make it similar or different?
MALIKA CANTOR: Yeah, so I
think as I mentioned earlier,
the main difference is that
we don't actually invest.
We don't have a financial
relationship with the startups
that we work with.
There's various
reasons why that is
the case, one of them
being that actually it
would be very complicated
for Google to have
a financial relationship
with some of the startups
that we're bringing in from
different places in the world.
You mentioned China earlier.
We're very excited
to be able to work
with companies without
having some of that red tape.
But it's also because we want
to make it very clear that this
is not a strategic
endeavor for Google,
and that this is
almost a room of peers.
We have a lot to learn from you.
In many cases, we have
mentors from our product teams
at Google who come
to us and tell us
how much they've learned
from the startups
that they've been working with.
So that's one main difference.
The other one is,
as I also mentioned,
we admit companies
on a rolling basis,
so we don't really believe
in the concept of classes.
From my background working
with startups-- and Peter has
too-- a lot of
people on our team
were very conscientious
of the fact
that startups can't just
drop everything every once
in a while and say,
OK, we're going
to go in and join this program
and basically not focus
on product development
for however long.
And so the entire
program is designed
in a way that's trying to
be very mindful of that
and is saying, look, you're
closing your round right now.
It might not make sense for
you to join this program,
but in a month when we
onboard our next batch,
we'd love for you to come in.
So that's the other one.
The third aspect I'd say that
is a little bit different
is that we have no size fits
all-- no one size fits all.
So it's completely
tailored to each company.
We admit companies
that have 12 people
and have raised
$100,000 and companies
that have about 1,000 people
and raised $70 million.
So that's kind of the
spread that we already
have in our current batch.
And so you can imagine
that a company that
has 12 people and
a company has 1,000
needs very different
kinds of support.
So we actually really
focus on identifying
what are the challenges
of each company,
and then build a totally custom
mentorship program and solution
for each company, which is
one of the reasons we only
work with very few
companies at a time.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Both of you talked about
that feedback loop,
which sounds fantastic.
And I think that
sounds wonderful.
I'm super curious to know--
what's been the most interesting
or surprising feedback
that you've got or learning
that you've had from working
with these companies?
MALIKA CANTOR: Peter,
do you have any so far
that you'd like to share?
PETER NORVIG: I think it's
just that companies are really
focused on solving their problem
and serving their customers,
and so they see the technology
as a way towards that goal.
And the technology itself,
exactly what it is--
they don't care as long
as you can get there.
And so making it easier for
them to take advantage of that
is what we're trying to do.
MELANIE WARRICK: So one of
the questions that I had--
you both were saying this,
and I've heard this a lot
lately, where people will
interchange AI and ML.
How do you define it?
How do you think about it in
regards to especially working
with these startups?
PETER NORVIG: So I guess I
define artificial intelligence
as doing something smart--
so figuring out what you want
to do and doing it well in a way
that you didn't know
how to do before.
So in some ways, I say that
regular software is defining
a program to do something
that you know how to do,
and AI is doing it for something
that you don't know how to do.
And then machine
learning just means
you're going to do that
by learning from examples
rather than having the
programmer write down
some rules or something.
And back in the 1980s,
we had the term AI,
and we also had the
term expert systems.
And what that meant is you
got an expert in medicine
or whatever it was, and
you interviewed them,
and you figured
out what they knew.
And then you wrote
down rules that
represented what they know.
And so that was AI by
applying expert knowledge--
figuring it out by hand.
Now, we tend not to do that.
We find that that's
brittle and slow.
And instead, we do it by
collecting data and learning
from the data.
So machine learning is achieving
AI through applying examples,
and expert systems is achieving
AI through understanding
knowledge.
MELANIE WARRICK: And we also
were talking a little bit
before.
I just wanted to
touch on it briefly
before we start to wrap up.
But you've got this great
experience working in China
and seeing where their world
is going around the AI space.
So just as a general thought
of where AI is leading us
for real world
business applications,
what's your perception
of this ecosystem?
MALIKA CANTOR: Yeah.
I think it was extremely
exciting to see Fei-Fei
open the AI Research Institute
in Beijing mid-December
last year.
PETER NORVIG: A lot of
interest and excitement
and a lot of people
working on it.
And we're seeing new
things coming up.
MARK MANDEL: So for anyone
who's listening and is all like,
I've got a business,
and we're doing ML,
and this program sounds amazing.
How do they get involved?
Is there a way?
MALIKA CANTOR: Yes.
So just go on our website.
There's an application.
It only takes about 10
minutes to fill out.
We would love to get an
application from you.
You're actually allowed to
apply even if you're not
working on health
care and biotech,
because we're looking at
applications to also influence
the next industry verticals
that we'll be announcing.
So again, we're admitting
companies on a rolling basis.
Applications are open
across industry verticals,
but we will be working mostly
with companies in the health
care and biotech space
in the next few months.
Also, if you aren't
a startup but would
like to refer a company,
please reach out to me.
And maybe we can even
share my information.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Yes, we'll definitely
have them in the show notes.
MALIKA CANTOR: And
then the final thing
is also if you are a subject
matter expert, because I think
one of the big
themes in this talk
was basically effectively
moving AI machine learning out
of the hands of just AI experts
and moving them increasingly
into the hands of subject
matter experts like health
care and biotech experts.
If you are a health
care and biotech expert
or someone else in
another industry,
you're really passionate
about applying
machine learning and
AI to your industry
and you'd like to
become a mentor,
again, please reach out.
We work with academics,
with industry veterans,
with ex-CEOs.
We'd love to hear about your
experience and your expertise.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Nice that you give it
such a breadth in terms of being
willing to take in the mentors.
One of the things I know
we were talking about
before was that you guys
have an event coming up
in a couple weeks.
Do you want to tell us
a little bit about that?
MALIKA CANTOR: Sure.
So basically, it's our
second high touchpoint.
So that's what we call the event
when the startups basically
fly in.
In certain cases, we
have two companies
that are based outside the US
and two companies in the US
right now, and they
come and basically
get few days to a week of back
to back workshops and meetings
with a lot of Google
teams and external mentors
like I mentioned.
So our next high
touchpoint is coming up.
We're going to be onboarding
a few new companies.
So if you're interested
in seeing what
other types of use
cases and companies
we're going to be
supporting moving forward,
definitely keep an
eye on our website
and on our Google
Developers blog.
And yeah, we're
really excited to keep
working with these companies,
and as we mentioned,
develop product methodologies
for machine learning
and hopefully build better
tools for this whole ecosystem.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
Is there anything else that
you both wanted to touch on
before we close out?
This is really great to
hear about Launchpad Studio
and get some insights
in terms of how
you're supporting startups.
MALIKA CANTOR: Yeah.
I guess the only thing is if
Peter has any other thoughts,
because him and I have had a lot
of conversations about this--
about his interest and
passion, and again, basically
empowering people
who aren't AI experts
across different industries.
PETER NORVIG: I guess we really
enjoy working with companies
and understanding
what their needs are
and what kind of tools
they want and how
we're going to build that.
And we see that as real
challenges going forward.
So I think a good
example of that
is with speech
recognition, where
we've made great strides
in the last few years--
where now you can
talk to your phone,
and we're going to get
most of the words right.
But now there's a next big step
of you got all the words right,
but how do you respond
to those words?
And that doesn't have to
do just with language,
that has to do with what is it
that you're trying to achieve.
And so we've got to give
the companies the capability
to say, when I
recognize these words,
here's what I should
do, and do that in a way
that they can
understand and build
a good product without having
to be experts in speech
recognition and machine learning
and linguistics and everything
else but just integrated
into their product.
And again, it's like in
regular software engineering.
We figured out how to build
menus and buttons and mouse
clicks over decades,
and now we have
to do the same thing
with a speech interface.
And it's all going
to be new, and we
don't know how to do it yet.
So we're looking to
partner with companies
and help figure
it out the other.
MALIKA CANTOR: Yeah, so
I think to Peter's point,
it's almost like come and
help us learn, and teach us
what you need.
And we're really excited about
working with a lot of people.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
And actually, just
one other question.
Peter, what got you inspired
to do AI in general?
What got you into the field,
if I may ask this slight side
note?
PETER NORVIG: It just seemed
like a really exciting field.
And I was in high school,
and I was lucky enough
that my high school
had both a computer
class and a linguistics class.
So it was rare that you had
computers in high school
in those days.
And I took those two
classes and said, hey,
could we put these two together?
And my teacher
wisely said, yeah,
it's possible, but not
with what you know.
So ever since, I've
been trying to learn
enough to be able to do it.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's
great that she gave you
that kind of challenge and
that you took the challenge.
I'm glad you both
were able to join us.
Thank you so much for
sharing the information
around Launchpad Studios.
And anything else that
you wanted to mention
or anything else that you wanted
to plug before we wrap this up?
MARK MANDEL: All right.
Well, thank you
very much to both
of you for taking the time
today and having a chat with us.
MALIKA CANTOR: Thank you
so much for having us.
PETER NORVIG: Yeah, thanks.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thanks Malika and Peter
for that great interview.
We appreciated the insights
around Launchpad Studio,
especially for
those startups out
there that are machine
learning and want
to have access to different
tooling and resources.
If you have any questions
or want additional insights
on Launchpad Studio,
we will, as always,
put links on our website.
And now, let's talk about
the question of the week.
So mark, if I am a startup, and
I want credits to work on GCP,
what is available to me?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So we have a whole
startups program.
We may have talked about it
previously on the podcast,
but I think it's changed
a little since then,
which is kind of cool.
So if you're a startup
and you're like, oh, man,
I really want to use
Google Cloud for it,
you can go to
cloud.google.com/startups.
And it will show you the
startup page, which is here.
And there are
different tiers that
are available right now for
different types of startup
packages.
So you can get anywhere from
$3,000 in credit all the way up
to $100,000 in
credit for one year,
including as well 24/7
support, office hours,
Spotlight all sorts
of different things
depending on what tier
you're on and what
sort of needs you have.
There are several-- actually,
we've had Descarte Labs--
which have been on the
podcast more than once--
is one of those people who
came through that program.
The one thing to know though--
if you are a startup
and you're looking,
and you want to come
through this program,
you need to apply through
your incubator, accelerator,
or VC firm.
There's a long list
of all those people
that we work with--
our platform partners.
I think I counted 142.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
That's good number of
people to be working with.
So yeah, if you
are small business,
and you're looking
for some credits,
it gives some insights in terms
of the size, what that means,
a little bit of
information around who
would qualify for the program.
Check out our link.
You'll see that
there's Start package,
there's a Spark
package, and there's
a Surge package in terms
of the number of credits
that you can
potentially get hold of.
And this can be applied to
all of GCP and Firebase.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
Actually, that's a
really good point
that it goes to both
GCP and Firebase,
which is also super cool.
If you aren't part of
one of those groups--
those incubators or
accelerator programs--
there is a mailing list
you can sign up for just
to get updates-- to
see if anything changes
or if new people come on board.
That's there, and
obviously free trial
is also obviously available.
MELANIE WARRICK: There we go.
Well, that wraps us up for
at least our first interview
out the gate for 2018.
Anything you want to
actually share or any
places you're going to be
in the next couple weeks?
MARK MANDEL: I'm not
traveling very much.
Q1 for me is very quiet.
Normally I'm just
sitting around trying
to get things done
for Game Developer's
Conference in
March-- just trying
to get ramped up for that.
How about yourself?
You off anywhere?
MELANIE WARRICK:
Nothing to announce
right now, but probably later.
MARK MANDEL: Good
stuff coming up.
All right, cool.
Well, Melanie, thank
you for joining me
for the first episode
of the year of 2018.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's done.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it's
done, and thank you
all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]